foreign
[Music]
what's up my babies it's the
congratulations podcast
uh October 19th I'll be in Pittsburgh
Cleveland Ohio I will be October 20th
Detroit Michigan the 21st Orlando
Florida the Don't Push Me Tour is coming
to Orlando Florida November 10th Fort
Myers November 12th November 17th
Richmond Baltimore Philadelphia reading
and then I just added some Oxnard
California dates where I'm going to be
doing some new material December 15th
through December 16th Oxnard Levity Live
and that's over in uh near Los Angeles
um and uh so that's what's going on here
you know
um but uh we're gonna do right now the
next episode of congratulations
[Music]
congratulations
I can't wait till this podcast is AI
honestly and I just don't really have to
do [__] uh it'll be a while though I
think we've been doing this podcast now
for how long has it been it's been since
2017 13 36 years uh so uh and that's
just how quick I am at math right it's
just how quickly I'm a math
um I bought a new scale I bought an eye
massager and I bought deodorant those
are my Amazon purchases
um Amazon's crazy kind of it's going
Amazon's crazy my son's three and a half
and he just will see something on TV and
it'll be like oh let's get that on
Amazon and I'm just like
all right
you know I just realized actually I have
this here and I I don't know why I must
be because I was blowing my nose but
every time I um I have this next to my
bed and the reason why I have this next
to my bed is because I wake up with a
dry nose and I need to blow it so I can
breathe that's why
and I always think in the middle of
night when I do that I wake up and I
think man got to get kleenexes because
this seems like I'm J I'm I'm squirting
right this this next to my bed seems
like
um I'm I'm I'm in the J files right I'm
I'm I'm I'm I'm I'm going spanking right
I'm not though dude it's for my nose it
really is for my nose I don't use it for
spanking
and every morning I wake up 3 30 in the
morning I can't breathe take this blow
my nose
and every time the cleaning ladies come
over I'm like dude they probably think
that these are for my spank files and
they're not dude
and now I'm like why why is this here I
must have been blowing my nose but
anyway if you don't know what I'm
holding if I'm you're listening to it
I'm holding a roll of toilet paper I
just have it next in my bed like I'm
some college student you know but really
I'm a 43 year old man with two kids
sleeping next to a wife I don't do it
okay yeah now do I Square yeah but do I
you know I don't
you know I don't use that to clean up I
just kind of like rub it on my underwear
and then go to bed and roll over
disgusting but whatever dude it doesn't
matter you know it really doesn't matter
it does oh it does matter honestly
because
lately uh I have to kind of click
I don't want to talk about this okay
honestly because it's disgusting to talk
about the pocket to start off with the
squirting monologue right
um I mean for for Christ's sakes my
parents listen to this podcast great
dude and also it's immortalized forever
my sons are going to hear it great dude
Billy just got his shots I don't know
what they have vaccinated him for
something they put one and one they
dipped it on his mouth and the other one
on his leg and I was holding them
actually Kristen was holding them and I
was right there holding two kind of but
she was doing most of the whole another
one to take credit for it and they just
poked him and he got he was smiling dude
he's such a smiley baby he was just like
this and then he goes
ah
that's it dude my sons get through their
emotions very quickly
um and that'll probably uh that probably
be hell for them later uh I keep
my walls up I've kept my walls up for a
long time but let's not get into it but
yeah but then anyway the floods came
crashing in and it's all good in my
babies
um yeah leave a message uh under here uh
when's last time he cried I'd love to
know it when's last time you cried leave
a message under the comments uh leave a
comment on the in the in the things you
know I always say leave a message and
that's absolutely ridiculous but um
yeah because I'm about iron Boomer or
whatever posted some clips going dummy
viral on some Tick Tock and Instagram
[__] you know I'm just uh I must throw a
guy out I was in Canada
uh this past weekend I was in Canada I
did Montreal I did Ottawa and I did uh
Toronto well I did Hamilton I will be
back in Toronto in Hamilton as well in
March but uh I didn't post those dates
yet but dude I was in
the things you go watch the tour report
in the other Chrisley Channel
but I was watching I was in the Montreal
show and let me just break this clip
down for you I did I was doing a joke I
do a joke where this the setup to the
joke is I say it and then I wait about
six seconds
to say the the punchline I hate saying
punch lines that's corny as [__] and I
don't like quote-unquote jokes but the
part that makes people laugh
I say six seconds later because in with
for six seconds I'm acting like the guy
who doesn't know what he's gonna say and
then says the thing now in this six
seconds when I'm waiting playing the guy
this other guy in Montreal screams out
a punch line that is not as good as my
punchline that I'm gonna do
but what does that do it [__]
everything up and then when I do mine
it's not as funny because everyone's
like oh that guy just yelled out all
right now he
ruined that part of the show it's
probably the hardest laugh in the whole
hour
Maybe
and he ruined it okay
uh
I got really mad you know
now look in the clip I look beefy as
[__] I'm working out a lot of people are
like are you on testosterone let me just
squash it right there no your boy does
all natural Fitness you know he eats
lean except for when he's on the road he
[__] up and eats a spicy crispy chicken
sandwich right he does do that okay he
eats a burger and fries he does do that
okay will he will he walk by a donut
store will he grab one he does do that
you know what I mean if he's getting a
coffee in the morning does he see scones
and maybe he would maybe he'll house one
or two maybe he'll maybe he'll do that
right maybe he will do that okay will he
get eggs will he get the bread and the
eggs and if they come will he put it off
to the side sometimes but will they also
house that how's the bread sometimes
yeah he did it'd be one big happy family
in his mouth right
be some bread some scones some ice cream
and a burger right yeah how's all of
them
right
hey all the bad food move in do you know
what I'm saying co-parent in this
[__] okay right
so
yeah I'm not on trt do I want to take it
yes have I been thinking about it yes
have I been thinking about taking hitch
yes have I done it no have I no people
also talk about oh why does he dye his
hair and not his beard have I ever dyed
my hair no I will die at Silver once I
start getting it I'm gonna dude I'm
gonna get the full Raiden all right but
anyway I'm getting off topic yeah I look
beefy it's my shoulders mostly doing all
the work but whatever dude
the guy chirped out I went to go kick
him out I said dude now this is
something I say all the time if I gotta
kick a guy out in America I go like this
who said that to the security the
security goes like this
it's too hard to see it's too hard to
see the people because they're in a sea
of people and they're yelling out
something
so uh
I never really expect them to find it in
Canada I say who did that the Canadian
security guard goes like this
him right there
and I was like oh and now I'm looking at
the guy and I say all right well if you
know who it is throw him out
so the security walks over they say yo
you gotta go and the guy goes oh man
sorry Chris I love you anyway felt bad
ruined the show for everybody ruin the
show for 12 for 1300 people felt bad
why because he's a big softie that's
what my mommy said and I just talked to
her on the phone she said I'm a big
softy
oh for [__] sake he's a softy she said
I know you're a softy and I was like I'm
a big softie in a way right
softie brothers and
um
so
now I say all right he could stay I feel
bad my anger subsides cool all good
anger subsides
that's how angry I get I'm also better
with my anger now okay now
that's fine the clips over there it's
doing great
so I'm thinking about my anger I talk
about my anger on stage a little bit
another guy
chimes in and I I get mad it's all clip
online but whatever I'm here talking
about anger
so I get through the whole weekend
I do my Hamilton show holy [__] it's
gangbusters all good he keeps the seats
warm but not too warm because they stand
up you know what I mean so
um and
we're going back to
the airport to leave the airport in
Toronto
my driver is
one of those races where you're like I
don't know what race that is do you know
what I mean
like as a white guy I'm I'm pretty sure
all white guys we know there's this race
out there where we're just like
you got me right like Asians you can
tell
blacks uh
uh Indians you get it right now we can
understand Samoans after like the last
10 years the rock and all that [__]
even though he's you know I don't know
if he's from moan but like we get it
right
whatever my driver is that's the white
guys we know what what I'm saying he was
that race the race where you look at him
and you go the [__] is that guy like a
Filipino or something but why is he not
have the eyes that they have right okay
whatever that race is that's what the
driver is and I
I don't I'm not the kind of guy that's
like I don't see color dude I see color
I recognize color I appreciate it I
respect it
so I see the driver on I go don't know
what race he is see it check it respect
it let's get up in this SUV
we get up in the SUV all five of us all
right
we're in the SUV
driving to the airport now Toronto's got
one of those airports that's in Toronto
and then they've got the airport that's
a little too far and it's so annoying
that they have it there and that's the
one I'm getting in okay it's like
Pearson or something I gotta go like 40
minutes but really it's 50 minutes and
I'm [__] driving out I'm in the
freeway
in the car
whatever race the guy is who's driving
is driving all of a sudden Sam my
videographer working on my [__] Sam's
computer comes flying forward why
because the driver is screeching okay
meaning we almost get no accident
meaning I'm like maybe the guy is
Filipino right because Asians always be
crashing
but he's not though I still don't really
know what a raise he is okay
we almost Screech I hear because here's
the thing when you're about to get into
an accident it's not the almost accident
that is gonna make you get in an
accident it's the afterwards right
because you're like I can handle this I
can handle this I got this i got this i
got this we stop and then after that
it's up to all these other Knuckleheads
behind you to navigate and see what the
[__] is going on to avoid you right and
those people aren't you and that means
they're idiots
so you go like this
and then you go let's hope for the best
there's nothing you do at that point
you know it's like in horror movies when
that [__] stupid shot that they do
where somebody opens the fridge door
looks in the fridge and the music is
happening and then they close the fridge
and not and you know either someone's
standing there or they're not standing
there but they've done it so many times
that you're like oh [__] they're gonna
close the refrigerator door and it's
gonna show a guy right that's the same
thing as waiting for that accident you
just kind of hope for the best Hopefully
the guy isn't there from the fridge
hopefully we're not gonna get hit in the
back
so I hear
and I'm like oh it's coming closer [__]
brace yourselves hell and they just
drive by okay so I'm like wow we made it
out
all good
we continued driving we're at a zero
mile an hour thing then we start going
again then I hear more honking then I
look to the left and then I see three
people in that car going like this to my
driver
just [__] flipping them off like this
like like big ones too not you know how
some people do it like that they had
their full fingers like that just being
like
red as [__]
craziest thing was
no clue what race they are okay so now
I've got a full-on
race war
with two races I don't know what they
are which is fine
but also the guy's super red because
he's so mad so I don't even really know
what color he is
so they're doing the thing where they're
like you know trying to to the SUV and
my driver's going like yeah yes yeah
yeah sorry sorry whatever his accent is
my tour manager in the back is like just
let him go let him go guy lets him go
okay so now they're in front of us so
now I'm like okay it's probably over
we're behind them all good
in front of us
window
driving just like this guys just driving
like this flicking the flipping the dude
off behind us
my driver
goes like this
the guy in the front turns around
I mean I've never seen red like this and
he goes
my driver goes like this
to you
I would have if somebody did that to me
I would have shot myself in the head
that is the most disrespectful thing to
do when somebody's mad is to look at
them and go
and he did that the guy gets out of his
car walks over to our car and is so mad
and then spits on our car
walks back and drives away
and I was just thinking about it man
about how long that guy was angry you
know
he was angry for minutes and not just
angry blood curdling angry
so I guess what I'm saying is
I'm pretty proud of myself for just
getting angry and then letting it go
I feel like that guy was in a bad place
though you never know what people are
going through right like what if that
guy just found out his dad you know got
uh you know stabbed in the [__] eyes
you don't know dude you don't know
you don't know
but the shows in Canada were awesome
Hamilton is on fire right didn't stay
there obviously because it's Hamilton
and is 50 minutes away from Toronto and
why would I stay in Hamilton everyone
says it smells like piss didn't smell
like piss it's actually very nice
um but Toronto is crazy awesome it's
just crazy awesome
it's just crazy awesome they got great
shops and then you know why they're
awesome because they have really good
shops next to really shitty shops and
you're like you got to find them so when
you find a cool place you're like oh
yeah this is kind of extra special just
coffee shops you know we stayed at that
one hotel which was really cool really
nice I mean they do this annoying thing
where it's like a lot of us are
sustainable and we make stuff furniture
out of [__] trees and all that which
I know they do anyway like a lot of
furniture is made out of trees but they
make it a point to let you know that
they're made out of like trees and [__]
because they got like you know their
unfinished wood and like their bench has
like [__] you know the like brown you
know it'll be like a nice like uh like
this color desk but like they'll have
the really Brown hole in it because
there was a branch coming out of the
tree and you got to be like oh this is
great and it says something like
sustainable on it and you're it's like
dude I don't give a [__] is it
comfortable you know
eco-friendly
I don't know I don't think we should be
eco-friendly if I'm honest just live it
up you know I'm talking about Live It Up
We're on Earth One Shot no yeah you got
to make it better for the generations to
come but here's the deal everyone in the
world is gonna [__] it up for them
anyway
you think the trees give a [__] you know
what I'm talking about you think we're
gonna get to the trees can back at us
you think the ozone layer is going to
deteriorate before some guy hits the red
button and I'm talking about
you think you think that the CO2 is
going to deplete before some guy in some
chair somewhere just hit some [__]
button that blows up half the world nah
and then we get some Dark Skies nah dude
drink Arrowhead bottled water
use lots of hairspray don't buy electric
you know what I'm talking about
we're all gonna get shot in the [__]
face anyway
I'm a nihilist
but that's it
whatever it is dude
I hope that Calvin and Billy are okay
here's the other thing too we got other
planets you know you think that it's you
think that we're not gonna be able to
move to one of those planets
[__] you think we're not gonna be
able to go to Mars I know it's real cold
or whatever whatever Saturn maybe it'll
be [__] up but what about that ring I
have a picnic legs off you know what I'm
talking about like the construction
workers like that one picture we're all
eating sandwiches on that high beam
that's me on Saturn with my family and
[__] 20 80.
I'll be dead
how about this my mother-in-law went to
Ireland got me this
dude
I'm on my [__] peaky Blinder dude
wow dude you know what's funny about
hats like this
you might put it on and be like huh in a
store and get it and then bring it home
and be like I'm a piece of [__]
whoa I look like a [__] raging
[__] huh like imagine a guy like this
is like yeah just take a left and then a
right and then you'll see it
you know what I mean imagine a guy like
this just oh this is oh this dude I
directed Brothers McMullen oh this dude
oh
I directed a movie called somewhat
somewhere oh dude oh my God I directed a
movie that [__] lost at Sundance holy
[__] look at the hat I got on
oh man
I'm a guy that calls movies pieces holy
[__] dude get out of here
oh God damn it dude why don't I have a
twisty mustache when I wear that but
anyway though
um
the writer strike is over I guess I
didn't know that that would be happening
but they say they reached a kind of a
deal
wgam amp TP too many [__] letters
reach historic contract agreement to end
146 day writer strike this deal is
exceptional
what is it dude
they can't use uh
uh groundbreaking additions to the wga's
minimum basic agreement the nitty-gritty
details language are used to generate AI
um
cool
well congratulations to the
people to the writers
um
to be clear no one is to return to work
until they
um
okay
that doesn't matter you know they'll
still use AI
writers will use AI that's the thing
basically this whole thing was like you
know
this is good for three years
oh man in three years we're gonna be
striking again we
uh Taylor Swift and Travis Kelsey Kelsey
is uh they're going out together and
they went to
um
uh of his football game and she wore
Converse and Converse sold out and he
wore an outfit
and his outfit sold out and then his
jersey sold out
so
okay
everyone
come on
get the other outfits get the outfits
that you want right
you're looking at a [__] shoe that
someone else wore and you go ah here's
the thing Kelsey Travis Kelsey wore the
outfit that that bedroom blue
bedroom that this guy it's called the
Blue painting bedroom the bedroom
painting outfit whatever he wore and
um you'll find it online and post it but
uh and then whoever created that bedroom
painting jacket
renamed it when they saw Travis Kelsey
uh wear it to the 1989 jacket
because that is synonymous with
Taylor Swift and then they sold out so
everyone he took you everyone it could
so that's
what happened
so the jersey sales were through the
roof not because of the way he plays but
because he's doinkin that is absolutely
crazy and he's good Travis because he's
good but that's the power of Taylor
Swift
that's a power of the punani that's the
power
of how good she is at singing and kind
of dancing even though she's bad at
dancing that's the power she has
of of doing I could name here's the
thing about uh
Taylor Swift
hey Chris do you know any Taylor Swift
songs nope hey also Chris when I'm in
the car oh I know this song who is it
Taylor Swift right
I gotta start dating Taylor Swift so my
[__] life rips line goes nutty goes
absolutely nutty
no dude I'm not gonna date her man I'm
married and I love I love my wife you
know what's crazy is
um I was gone for six days with my wife
and my kids and I [__] miss them big
time dude
I never really knew what missing was
honestly because I had my walls up I
never really knew what uh missing what
missing someone was I didn't get it I
didn't know if it was a feeling or not
or I thought it was just something that
people said I was like a robot I was
like one of those robots in one of those
[__] movies where it's like why are
your eyes raining that doesn't
understand crying even though they would
know the word crying because it would be
in their database some writer thinks
it's cute to say have the robot say why
are your eyes raining that was me dude
when it came to missing someone is it a
longing is it is it a longing or is it
just a word and then I had kids and now
not only do I miss my kids I miss my
wife what the [__] he misses too much
and she sends videos and I'm like oh
[__] I love it you know
um
look at this Martin Scorsese just an old
guy huh
love it talented is all get out just an
old you can't fight that [__] you just
become old and then you become just the
old guy right
like I didn't know how to do something
on my phone the other day and I was just
like oh it's just not for me I'm 43
that's not what I'm gonna do
oh yeah
I go like this yeah I was at this place
in uh Toronto I can't remember what the
place was called really great staff and
all that [__] with the workers
they go I late at night I look on the
menu if hey dude if a menu says
Smashburger oh hey dude if a menu says
Smash Burger in it anywhere I'll locate
it I'll locate it like robocot trying to
figure out how to Ricochet the bullet
off the wall to get the bad guy who's
kidnapped the girl do you know what I'm
saying it's just like
Smash Burger located like this
and then all of a sudden
I'm ready
Smashburger
double Patty cheese melted cheese
Special Sauce
I'm reading hello I would like a Smash
Burger hello I would like one Smash
Burger
what kind of fries would you like sweet
potato fries am I a [__] [__] no I
would like regular fries what size am I
a [__] communist [__] I would like
large
if I'm getting a Smash Burger it totally
defeats the purpose
if I go small
get it [__] whoops sorry it's
autocorrect autocorrect woman and
um
so let's bleep that out so um
so if I see Smashburger dude
oh my mouth is getting clogged up
right
if I see if I so much as did a glimpse
of the word Smash in front of burger oh
I'm going quiet for a bit right
in 15 minutes my mom's the word dude
remember when they just started doing
Smash Burgers and everyone started
saying less and shutting the [__] up
because of how tasty to smashed patties
are in between
and
put brioche on it dude
put brioche on it
go ahead hey dude I'll just eat a
brioche bun like I'm a goose
just
in parts
brioche and smash
come on bro
again clogged up
mouthwise and artery wise
so I'm eating the Smashburger but I go
like this somebody in my crew gets a
spicy Nashville chicken sandwich okay so
the waitress says now just so you know
it's really spicy and the guy who's
Mexican in my Camp says
yeah it's okay I'm Mexican I'm used to
spicy stuff and she said I was gonna say
you're not white and everyone laughed
and I laughed
I didn't really think it was all that
funny not because I was offended just
because I'm like I get that's the joke
but also
we're in dangerous territory somebody
could get fired
we're talking about rays
foreign he gets the spicy chicken
sandwich
and so does another guy Denny the guy I
bring on the road to do some time before
me
he eats the Nashville spicy chicken
sandwich he goes this is too spicy it's
not good it's too overwhelmingly spicy
Enrique
the Mexican guy says it's really spicy
but I love it and he eats the whole
thing
now
oh I'm curious
I really want to try this Nashville
chicken sandwich because I love spicy
stuff you saw my hot hot ones episode I
flew through it if you can't get through
the hot ones that [__] honestly you're
kind of a [__]
I'm cool with that [__] it wasn't a big
deal
so I they say do you want to try mine
because I'm not going to eat it and I go
like this no it's tainted I get my own
[__] I don't really bite [__] from
people's sandwiches I might but I damn
well won't do a sip thing from another
person's soda and and that's like a
white thing that people do a white white
people are like try it like my friend
David Sullivan is always like you want
to try my [__] it'll be like a gross
like a milkshake and you're like bro
it's all pink in your mouth I'm not
doing it
and uh so I say no I'm gonna get one
so they go okay it's really spicy I say
to the lady to the waitress I said I
want that it comes over I take a bite
it's tremendously spicy
I ate the whole thing
and it was great now the reason why I
say this when I'm talking about Martin
Scorsese remember what I was saying he's
just the old guy
because he was saying
he wants to fight back I didn't say this
yet but he wants to fight back against
comic book movie culture supported by
directors like Christopher no no we've
got a safe Cinema is fine and he's just
being the old guy and in this situation
I wasn't the old guy yet
but I was the old guy when I got home
I shut my brains out
my feet were off of the floor like Jeff
Daniels in
Dumb and Dumber
and it was fine
didn't burn
but
I evacuated my bowels then I went to bed
then I woke up and I felt okay I was
like good thing I evacuated my bowels
last night
and now I could just kind of do my thing
so I went I got a cup of coffee I drank
it and then I got my gym clothes on and
I went down to stairs to do the gym at
the one hotel
and I did some lunges yeah naturally I
got beefy like that I also did some
other things some shoulder stuff and in
the middle of the
workout
I was the old guy again
my stomach goes like this
I go hmm
I'd do another set
rare
walk into the bathroom
feet off the ground evacuate my bowels
never in my life have I sweat so much
then in that moment when I was in that
hot bathroom evacuate my bowels in the
middle of a workout dude I was so
glistening I was I might as well be the
main character in the shape of water it
was unbelievable dude it was
unbelievable so anyway man I'm the old
guy too Martin Scorsese but that's what
that's what I'm saying but
everything's changing nothing can be
saved yes Duty said it he's a nihilist I
get it I'm a nihilist I've said it
before but wow dude nothing can be saved
the ozone Cinema whatever it is Earth
Gone
Martin Scorsese we need says we need to
fight back against comic movie Culture
by supporting directors like Christopher
Nolan we've got to save Cinema
in a sprawling new profile with GQ I
don't like when they call articles
profiles like it's some like yo you
write you you write for a [__]
magazine okay
Martin Scorsese discussed some comic
book in French he does not like that
[__]
topic which he has spoken about at
length in the past
uh the danger there is what is doing is
what is doing to our culture because
there are going to be Generations now
that think movies are only those that's
what movies are
yeah but there's
I guess the widespread of the [__]
movies like Christopher Nolan are in
Jeopardy but they'll still always make
them
they already think that he said which
means that we have to then fight back
stronger and it's got to come from the
Grassroots level it's got to come from
the filmmakers themselves
and you'll have you know the softy
Brothers
and you'll have Chris Nolan you know
what I mean and hit him from all sides
wow it's it's movies dude guys acting
like it's [__] Dunkirk go out there
and do it Go reinvent don't complain
about it but it's true we gotta says
Cinema he said while complaining guys
acting like it's the Vietnam War you
gotta hit him from both sides dude softy
Brothers flank right Nolan flank left
oh [__] they just they just died
because they're [__]
[Music]
um
um let's do some of these uh what do you
call them
uh mouth uh what do you call them
the hauler holler dot baby dude
we've caught teamed up with holler dot
baby
um
to do these little quick things
for people that can purchase them
uh
so here's some unlock Financial Security
with McCune Financial Group today
call 563-549-8052
check out you don't be saying podcast on
Spotify
uh
uh slime though
slimed OKO
etsy.com slime do Co it's slime d-o-h-co
the best slime and sensory kits oh yeah
dude
Calvin likes that the sensory kit [__]
um
an N where slime men
s-l-i-m-e-n-d-o-h-c-o there we go that's
what it is
etsy.com s-l-i-m-e-n-d-o-h-e-o
[Music]
what's that
um so yeah
dude my mom fell and broke her hip it
[__] sucks
my mom keeps my mom keeps falling
because she's a Mom Mom's fall moms are
just like
moms will just be hanging out and then
be like oh [__]
and then you're like what the [__] was
it they're like I don't know a rock and
you're like you're in the kitchen
added that into the mix everyone's going
down you know what I'm talking about my
mom was just walking my dad backed up my
mom whoa
now let me tell you something my mom is
the [__]
she's awesome awesome
she you don't even know when shit's
bothering her she just she goes whoops
fell uh all good goes to bed
you know chilling my dad's like what the
[__] happened to my mom's like you
bumped into me wakes up bruised ass
[__] hand
I check in what's up Mom she's like ah
I'm [__] my side hurts I go where
my brother goes over to visit a few
hours later just for shits
oh open the door hey what's up my dad I
haven't called 9-1-1 I think Mom's gonna
go to the hospital hey hey
sup
hey hey keep us abreast
hey hey what's going on
okay
they call me hello hey your mom's in the
hospital going to the hospital 9-1-1
what
okay we go turns out now I went to go
I'm a good son I go to the hospital
hey took some X-rays
she broke her hip I go online look at
people who break hips that are 74 years
old it's a death sentence I go the
doctors say don't worry about it it's
not that's just what's online I go
Whoopsie Daisy shouldn't have looked
online all good so she gets the surgery
all good fine
dude
the nurse there
Filipino guy I know the joke is if
Filipinos are all they're not they're
all nurses I get it
he goes like this
you know you know everyone's talking you
know you get to develop a rapport my mom
was in the hospital for a few days she's
out now she's good
uh
the Filipino nurse dude
we gotta Rapport all this [__] he says
uh yo
there was a uh a black guy here once
that we got admitted and um
one of the things that were uh that was
medical we had to make sure he wouldn't
eat any chocolate and there's chocolate
around the hospital
and uh
we want to make sure he wouldn't eat
chocolate so we put white gloves on his
hands
and he had to keep the white gloves on
his hands
so uh he wouldn't have
because so the chocolate come off and we
would know that he was eating chocolate
if you had if you had the gloves on
and we go like this oh
and then the guy says that's a joke
hey man
no it's not
it might not be true
but what
dude right away he said that's a joke it
didn't happen
bro
things like that
are the creme de La Creme of life
thank you for that
hey yeah the guy a black guy came in we
had a minute couldn't he um usually
couldn't eat chocolate and so we put
white gloves on him and then we came in
and he had chocolate all over his glue
he had Brown all over his clothes he
knew he was eating chocolate that's just
a joke
that was how he told it
dude and so that so now that's the top
joke
beat that
I mean I've worked
17 18 years to become
a professional comedian
nothing I've ever said is that funny
and nothing ever will be
because some Filipino nurse decided to
make a racist non-joke
oh my god dude
when I went to Canada I thought about
how it was being how about about like
you know because Canada gets a rep for
being woke it it really wasn't my my
jokes are not are are very uh
what do you call it not
they pushed the envelope hard and uh
the uh they were loving it right so I'm
like oh this is just these are just
people it's nice everyone knows this
woke [__] is [__]
and I was at the gym in Canada
and I did deadlifts and then I moved on
to another exercise and before and I
moved on to another another exercise
before I rewacked re-racked the weights
and I'm doing the other exercise I think
it was chest and as I'm doing this other
exercise a woman walks over and goes to
start mess with the deadlift stuff the
bar that I didn't re-wap re-wrack why am
I saying rewack
so I say while I'm working out I say oh
I'm sorry
um let me know if you need help with
that I'll do it after this and she says
oh I'm good
um
and also let me know if you need help
with anything
at first I was like Wow Canadians really
are nice but now I'm thinking she said
that
because of she wanted to make sure that
she knew that I knew that
women were equal and stuff and
sure but
not here
not at the gym also here's the other
thing I meant to just
be like sorry I didn't read I didn't
clean up after myself
but I think she took it as like hey
darling if you need me to lift anything
heavy
I'll do it because you may not be able
to do it because your tits and [__]
might be in the way like
I was just being friendly and then she
says let me know if you need help I
should have said oh dude yeah honestly
definitely grab those [__] uh 90
pound kettlebells so I can do farmers uh
walk with them I need I need help with
that pick that up for me
you can't
now neither can I but you can't
right I I can I can do a 80 I I'm
comfortable with not 90 but I mean maybe
90 but 80 I can go a few steps with so
but dude
afterwards I thought about it and I
didn't even want to bring it up to my
own self right like sometimes you're
doing [__] and you're like ah I'm never
gonna think about that again it kind of
made me uncomfortable and I didn't want
to break up to my own self and Denny who
I was with working out he said remember
when that happened you think that girl
said that because of that and said it
because of the equality thing and I was
like bro I didn't want to think that but
maybe maybe dude and so now I'm talking
about on the podcast what do you think I
don't know
I don't know not everybody can [__]
everyone's not equal you know I mean
everyone deserves the same rights but
everyone's not equal right some people
only have like one arm
you're not equal
you deserve the same rights but
people with no arms don't deserve the
same rights I'll say it
driving
I'm talking about operating a forklift
playing baseball
right socks
but not everyone's equal and not even
everyone deserves the same rights wow
that now that I think about it
uh-huh
paraplegic
swimming
right
you don't do that you can't it's against
the law because it's against the law to
kill yourself and that's basically what
that is I mean you need floaties I guess
but whatever dude I'm losing people left
and right but it's like
you know not everyone is created equal
remember that whole [__] in the 80s when
they'd be like everyone is created equal
then you'd see your friend with like
[__] one arm
then what
sure equal if they're playing you know
the slot machines but
dude have you guys seen this
Britney Spears I mean
honestly dancing in the kitchen with
knives first of all all of her videos
are in this room I feel like
but do it
let me be I don't know if anyone said
this because it's so weird
it is weird because it's dangerous and
like also our fire alarm needs batteries
but like
and she smiles in the middle of it she's
still kind of doing it Brittany
I mean almost step that's the double the
double is the real one that kills me
dude no pun intended
how about the fact that has anybody said
this
she's crushing it bro
that's like an awesome dance she's doing
and she's doing it with knives and she's
still got it the only thing people
should be saying is you still got oh
oh gonna cut her [__] fingers off
dude hey don't be doing that though
right because that's very dangerous but
also everyone's worried about you but
also
um you're crushing it
and
we made her crazy
and that's SEC right
they're not suck people don't want to
talk about how Fame [__] you up [__]
you up
yeah
if I were her I'd be dead no doubt no
doubt right after I shave my head I
would do it like this oh this looks bad
bang that would have been me
like oops thought this was a good idea
Bang
uh uh
my God I mean her dogs and [__]
her dogs are right there imagine in the
middle she just [__] stabbed herself
completely by mistake like that's just
too much man it's kind of actually hard
to watch wow
um
remember the [__] I always think
about when stuff like this happens I
think about I'm not going to look at it
because I don't want to like add to the
problem and this isn't really that big
of a deal but like remember when that
data leak happened where like all of the
celebs nudes came out it was like
Jennifer Lawrence and
it's happening now
oh the fappening was that what that
created really oh that's funny
um like I purposely didn't look that up
I still have not looked it up
and um
you two oh nice oh good oh where go go
[__] room full of good guys huh and
uh I just that sucks so I guess I what
I'm saying is I don't know what Jennifer
Lawrence's titties look like so and I'm
a good I'm good for that right
um
bro this is awesome
Club ax won't have to Fork over merch
money to Live Nation anymore Live Nation
announced a new program on Parkinson
which will Nelson and the merch fees
that have been widely decried by artists
thank you yeah
um
but this is only at clubs
no
um
that's cool dude it's a crime you go to
[__] um places and you try to sell
your merch and they take 20 to 25 to 30
percent of your merchandise you pave so
that means you pay for the merch
we pay for the merch
we pay for the shipping to get it all
there
we make some of the money and then we
have to give 20 or 30 of it away if
you're not making boatloads of cash at
former it's not even worth selling merch
it's so shitty when you gotta [__]
give them a few thousand dollars just to
pay the thing
it makes it yeah it's true dude this
person said on um
God the fees that they do are so the
fees that the ticket guys do and the
concert tickets are hard enough to get
you shouldn't have to pay surprise
service fees on top of that this is what
President Biden is saying it's probably
the only good thing he's doing but
um my Administration is working to crack
down on those junk fees so you know what
you're paying for up front
um
also cancel somebody said cancel merch
tax it makes it impossible for most
working artists to make a living yeah
that's true dude
um
yeah look at this
these are the states
20 percent
for DC 25 New York
20 Boston while there's none in New
Haven or Richmond that's cool I'm going
to be in Richmond better [__] make
sure that happened
uh Montreal 15
Ottawa none oh that's nice I was selling
an art in Ottawa
um
uh minimeneessages.com say anything to
anyone anywhere anonymously
Looking Glass podcast funny boys silly
gooses listen to it
bright colorful painted Pet Portraits at
tabs.paints dot pets on Instagram
smokeshowsauce.com promo code baby for
25 off
what's this one Italian we're two
Italian brothers from Australia we sent
you some pajamas baby slouch potato okay
I guess you sent me some pajamas when am
I getting it
um
let's do these tender ones
do people still use dating acts apps I
guess so accidentally swipe right
because I double tap the button what the
hell is up with people this person wrote
um do you
have
Percocets or lean wow
you know
civil rights what the [__] no
that this is not what Tinder is for the
hell and they write wait really I've
been using it for perks and lean since
2020.
wow dude is Lil Wayne on Tinder
swipe left
um
dude perks and lean
perks and Recreation
he blocked me at least I think I'm funny
this was one this one is
still no in-person dates how do you know
that it's in your bio LOL whoa lol it
was when I messaged you but just looked
and now it's not
are you okay he said yeah I'm literally
not even kidding when I looked at it
said due to covet no in-person dates he
said you're confusing me with another
profile he said I'm okay I'm very
confused right now let's restart hey how
are you and then the girl said I'm good
but you should know I'm not doing
in-person dates right now wow smashed
him dude
that's pretty uh
people get behind the screen of a
computer and a phone and they don't give
a [__] bro let's do this one
you guys got on Match here we go can I
be your slave yes will you use me as
your toilet no I will use the toilet as
a toilet wow
that's actually kind of weird I mean the
pissing thing I get the [__] I don't
get
I don't get
this [__] one is too much it's very
German yeah let's do it sure I don't
care about the actual um
smells of it haha
listen to Neon Shadows a Noir Tale on
Spotify there we go and you get those at
holler dot baby slash crystallia go
check those out for some say I'll say
whatever I'll you know
I'll uh
I'll say those [__] things you know
and people like it so you know it is
what it is
um but that's the end of the that's the
end of the episode today for uh
congratulations uh leave a comment and
go to chrissy.com get that merch and all
that stuff and check out where I am and
also if you want to listen to the that's
the end of the episode if you want to
listen to the rest of the episode the
full episode
um going over to patreon.com Chrisley we
have two years of episodes that it will
unlock immediately for just six bucks
ah so go check it out thank you very
much patreon.com
[Music]